[Música]
nadie imaginaría que esta mujer sufrió
en su piel la esclavitud fueron 38 años
de explotación
[Música]
para magdalena cada día es una conquista
fácil
no tenía derecho a hacer nada ahora lo
tengo me encanta a danzar saltar a hacer
deporte hacer de todo
comenzó a trabajar como doméstica a los
8 años sus patrones no le permitieron ir
a la escuela tampoco recibió un salario
ni tuvo un solo día de vacaciones
magdalena fue rescatada a finales de
yo quiero que usted llora de alegría de
aquí a poco ok vamos a enfrentar todo
eso juntos no la voy a abandonar su caso
conmocionó el país
en brasil como magdalena cerca de 57 mil
personas fueron rescatadas en los
últimos 25 años
madre lina qué tal
te he echado de menos esta empleada
doméstica ganó otra vida gracias al
inspector que lideró la operación de
rescate
hoy les une una amistad
ahora tiene motivos para arreglarse la
peluca el maquillaje le ayudaron a
recuperar la autoestima yo me levantaba
pronto a las 2 de la mañana y trabajaba
hasta las 8 de la noche de pie mi
columna no aguantaba más
sabías que las otras empleadas tenían
vacaciones y tú no las tenías yo sabía
todo dentro de mi cabeza lo sabía pero
yo decía no voy a hablar voy a quedarme
calladita sufría calladita aquí dentro
humberto le ofreció amparo durante los
primeros días fue una excepción en su
trayectoria en la que rescató a casi 900
trabajadores esclavizados así
me pareció una buena idea traerla aquí a
mi casa para darle este cariño
por primera vez desde su liberación
magdalena vuelve a la ciudad donde
conoció la esclavitud
ahora es dueña del piso de sus ex
patrones es parte de la indemnización
para compensar todos los años de trabajo
sin sueldo hola cómo estás ahora sí
[Música]
mala
gracias al testimonio anónimo de algunos
vecinos consiguió recuperar su autonomía
este era mi cuarto aquí es donde
guardaba la ropa abajo
es una habitación minúscula y sin
ventana
y este era mi baño ves hay que saltar
para salir magdalena quiere vender este
piso para comprar su propia casa
su historia ha inspirado nuevas
denuncias en un área laboral que no era
fiscalizada el primer rescate de una
doméstica fue realizado en 2017 desde
entonces 27 personas fueron liberadas
durante trescientos cincuenta años más
de cinco millones de africanos fueron
traídos a la fuerza a brasil fue el
último país del mundo occidental en
abolir la esclavitud en 1888
millones de afrodescendientes fueron
dejados a su suerte sin tierras ni
estudios
sin posibilidad de conseguir un empleo
como incluir a esta población en la
sociedad para los negros y los mestizos
solo sobre una ciudadanía de segunda
clase de tercera clase
víctor actual
este legado se arrastra hasta hoy el año
pasado el
77% de los trabajadores rescatados eran
negros
la esclavitud suele ser más común en las
áreas rurales
reencontramos a humberto en la misma
ciudad donde magdalena fue esclavizada
los inspectores realizan operaciones en
una hacienda de ajo y en 3 carbonerías
la policía impide nuestra entrada por
razones de seguridad
en total 130 personas son rescatadas en
tres días es la operación más grande del
año sin embargo ese esfuerzo no es
suficiente para erradicar el trabajo
forzoso acabe haciendo el rescate del
mismo trabajador varias veces esto
ocurre con una cierta frecuencia por
causa de una deficiencia del estado a la
hora de un hacer mejores condiciones y
la reinserción de éstos
el código penal de brasil prevé penas de
2 a 8 años de cárcel para los
explotadores pero la impunidad es muy
grande
brasil es una referencia internacional
en la lucha contra la esclavitud moderna
a pesar de los recortes de los últimos
dos gobiernos
magdalena se recupera de su larga
pesadilla y se prepara para tomar las
riendas de su vida sueña con su futuro
piso al que llevará sus primeras muñecas
un regalo tardío que recibió a los 47
años